- Welcome back.
We've got Whitney Cummings,
The Property Brothers,
and Andrea Pitter with us.
Give it up, y'all.
(audience applauding)
That was a clip from last
time Heidi Klum was here.
She restored me, I'm pretty sure.
We played a game in honor of
her show, "Making the Cut."
We now have the winner
of "Making the Cut" here.
So, it's time for another
round of "Making the Cut,"
but with--
(button dings)
(Whitney laughs)
- [Drew] Wait. Wait.
♪ Making the cut, but with what ♪
- [Drew] Oh, okay. Sorry.
- [Jonathan] Why don't we
get those long hand things?
- That's what we had to do in COVID.
We can touch it now.
- By the way, none of this
episode is going to make the cut.
But, it's been a blast.
- It's already been cut.
(laughing)
- Wait, teams are me
and Jonathan, winners,
versus Whitney and Drew, losers.
Andrea has graciously agreed to host.
So, take it away, Andrea.
(laughing)
Good luck.
- Okay. Fair and square.
In this quiz, the answer to each question
is something or someone that cuts.
The first team to hit the buzzer
and give the right answer gets the point,
and steals are allowed.
- [Jonathan] Wait, how do you steal?
- Oh, if they get it wrong.
- If they get it wrong.
- Oh, I see.
- When you get it wrong.
(laughing)
- Oh my God.
- I love you! I love you!
- I am so stressed out.
- If Kelly and Jonathan win,
the right side of the
audience gets a prize.
(Kelly mimics air horn blaring)
If Whitney and Drew
win, it's the left side.
And their photos go up
on the Blake Shelton Wall of Champions
who beat Kelly Clarkson.
- It's a dumb wall. It's a dumb wall.
- Why does that guy put
his name on everything?
- It's a dumb wall.
- "It's a dumb wall."
- Let's go. Here's the first question.
Paul Bunyan used one of these.
(button dings)
- Axe.
(bell chimes affirmatively)
(Kelly screams)
- What!
- Oh my Gosh! What!
- Okay, okay, okay. Okay. You know what?
- Hold on, she pays the producers.
- No! I have never seen--
- No, no, no, no.
I am, you know what--
- I have never seen a thing!
- The way-- how quickly someone answers
tells you everything you
need to know about the person
and their own stuff.
Kelly has bunions and
cuts them with an axe,
so that's why that came so quickly to her.
- No! You know those little
plays you had to do in school?
I always remembered him having an axe.
That's why, that's why.
- If you didn't buzz, I was gonna buzz.
- Yeah.
- Here's the next one.
This X-Man has claws--
(button dings)
- Yes!
- Yeah!
- You knew it!
- Wolverine.
(bell chimes affirmatively)
Boom.
- Bring it in!
- Boom!
- Are we still close?
- Yeah, no, you have to get closer.
- I love that he's like, so tall.
I'm like, doing this to his belly button.
- It's a belly button bounce, right there.
Hold on. Go sideways to the camera.
- Like, like, it's like,
it's like, this is--
(Kelly laughs)
- So the game is hit the button,
whether you have it or not.
- Yeah.
- Let's keep going.
(Whitney laughing)
If you pass gas,
you might be said--
(button dings)
- Come on!
- Gut disease!
- But there's that--
(bell chimes affirmatively)
- Yeah!
- What in the world!
Oh my God!
- It's not a game anymore.
It's rigged.
- We are on fire!
Here's the next one: During surgery--
(laughing)
- Uh, scalpel, scalpel, scalpel.
Scalpel.
- Scalpel.
(bell chimes affirmatively)
- Yes!
- See!
(audience cheering)
(Whitney laughing)
- That was amazing.
She said, "During surgery,"
I thought (indistinct)
- But wait--
- Let's do it again!
Let's do it, now that I
know we're in the game!
- This is the best part.
That was actually worth three points.
(bell chimes affirmatively)
(cheering)
- Yes!
(Whitney laughing)
- No! The last question is
always worth three points.
(Whitney laughs)
- [Drew] We're still in this!
- So we're tied!
How do we settle this?
- Uhh.
- Deathmatch?
- All right. Bring us scissors.
- [Kelly] That was amazing.
They cut, too.
- Tiebreaker.
- Okay, the tiebreaker.
Are we ready?
- Yes.
- Okay. You can cut up fruit--
(button dings)
- Oh.
- Uh, dicer. Dicer?
- No.
- No?!
- We get the whole question.
- You can cut up fruit and veggies
for your smoothie in one of these.
- (whispering) A Vitamix?
- Like, a blender?
- Like, a Vitamix?
- Yeah.
- No, no.
Microwave. Microwave.
- Do you have to be specific?
- Do you know those
things that cut apples?
It's like a circle, and you go--
- Oh! That was exactly the answer.
(cheering)
(bell chimes affirmatively)
- Boom!
- What did you say?
(audience cheering)
- Okay, well, hold on, hold on.
Let's just do one all-or-none.
One all-or-none.
(air horn blaring)
- Wait, I got this. It's okay.
Our side, I'm going to
renovate all your houses. So--